on voit bien que bon la vieille
opposition démocratie totalitarisme bon
aujourd'hui est bon elles fonctionnent
elles fonctionnent plus bien puisque man
mais il ya même des gens qui viennent
nous dire que la démocratie c'est le
totalitarisme wind renault entend
partout des choses du genre
les mauriciens totalitarisme bon il ya
un intellectuel célèbre qui a expliqué
que l'antiracisme ce raid totalitarisme
du 21e siècle va donc n'importe quoi
finalement peut être totalité déclaré
totalitaire quoi ce que j'en aime passé
totalitaire
voilà mes donc je dirais que on n'est
plus dans une espèce de partage donc
vous dire oui enfin il ya des lignes
qu'il ya des lignes de basse
effectivement bon en même temps dijon
malgré tout ce qui s'il ya démocratie
parce que éventuellement les gens
franchissent les lignes quoi bon c'est à
dire que bon je pense est quand même
tout ce qui s'est passé effectivement
bon depuis le printemps arabe
jusque bon là je jusqu'au mouvement né
en algérie beaucoup ces derniers temps
quoi on voit bien que or on est on est
dont le on est aidé en vendait et
d'andré d'enfants dans des dans des pays
où en principe la salle nombre de droits
à quoi bon en fait il y avait des gens
qui monopolisent le pouvoir et après ça
bon ben ya des gens qui décident en
quelque sorte d'exercer ses droits
qu'eux ils ont en principe mais qui
normalement sont pas reconnus il ya
cette espèce je crois de jeu finalement
au fond quelle démocratie c'est quand
même que les gens se donnent des droits
se donne des droits à eux mêmes
d'ailleurs que une certaine moment enfin
le moment bombe un bond a le courage on
a le courage de dire mais après tout
c'est pintail manifesté dont comme
gagner donc on m'a donc on manifeste
c'est pas interdit d' c'est pas interdit
finalement 2-2 de faire des actions
c'est pas interdit de laisser partir a
dit dé diffuser sur ses pas interdit non
c'est pas taris et contrôler le problème
c'est que pratique on est quand même
beaucoup dans les sociétés qui font les
sociétés effectivement de contrôle quoi
et je dirais que bon c'est en un sens ça
donne ça ça donne dieu ça donne du jeu
ça donne du jeu ça donne du jeu à
condition d'avoir véritablement dion le
courage d'agir quoi mais c'est pour ça
que je disais que si on signe et l'adedy
la démocratie disons comme ça qu'ils se
manifestent en ce temps ci c'est
beaucoup plus de dix ans sous la forme
de l'action de collectifs quoiqu'il moi
qui décide
on a le droit pas après tout on a le
droit ou non on a le droit d'être dans
la rue on a le droit de dire on a le
droit de dire ce qu'on veut
on a le droit de poser nos
revendications et voilà est bon et on
exerce et on exerce ce droit est au fond
il y en eu club bombe à la rue pour
justement pas pour dire que ben enfin on
est un peuple
[Musique]